on Remembrance weekend Ben Parkinson
makes sure his poppy is firmly in place
a bomb in Afghanistan left him brain
damaged and a double amputee he's been
going through intense rehabilitation but
his morale has suffered a setback he and
his family are upset after reading a
leaked memo sent to senior commanders in
Afghanistan suggesting wounded soldiers
would be made redundant from the Army we
know that with the incredible numbers of
wounded that there are that yes there
are gonna have to be tough decisions
made but it's who decides when that
times right it's got to be when a
soldier's rehabs finished when his
career progression is in place
you cannot just tip these boys out to an
uncertain future
Oh a damn good lad the Ministry of
Defence has robustly denied that the
leaked memo is factually correct
it was quoted by The Telegraph newspaper
stating that 2,500 injured soldiers
would not be speared in the wing defence
cuts we have no plans to change the
arrangements for dealing with personnel
who have been injured anyone who is
injured who is undergoing medical
treatment will not be eligible for
consideration for a redundancy program
so long as that medical treatment is
under underway head of Manning for the
Army Brigadier Richard Muji says it
wasn't an official document and was
written by a junior officer he along
with the rest of the mo Diaz angry it
was allowed to circulate amongst senior
officers in Afghanistan it was a young
captain as we understand it who was
writing from a reported telephone
conversation as we as I understand it to
his superiors in Helmand to keep them
abreast of some of the thinking that is
going on I'm responsible for reducing
the army and therefore I've got to look
at every possibility of how to do that
the growing amount of injured personnel
is clearly an issue for the army and
it's understood that once soldiers are
as fully rehabilitated as they can be
they will face the same cuts as others
but the timing of this leaked man what
was bad and it's sure to have affected
morale oh it's gonna be bad news for the
veterans you just have to say that and
the rumor mills and the barrack room
lawyers get going I think there are a
lot of commanding officers o'seas
commanding a platoon sergeants which
must be on the case now to straighten
this out the army is still considering
the criteria for 12 to the next wave of
redundancies but misinformation about
that is the last thing serving troops
meet changeable sky news